[موسيقى]
دبابات اليوبارد 2 التي تنتجها شركه كي ان
في الالمانيه
الجيش الالماني وكذلك لدى 18 دوله اخرى
حول العالم دبابه شاركت في الكثير من
المعارك من بينها مع قوات النيتو في
افغانستان وكذلك ايضا ضد تنظيم داعش في
سوريا
في ساحه المعركه كما انها تتمتع بمدفع
رشاش عيار 120 ملليمتر وكذلك ايضا هذه
الدبابه لديها منظومه التي تنتجها شركه
رفايل الاسرائيليه التي تحميها من
الصواريخ المضاده للدبابات كما انها ايضا
تحمل قاذفه قنابل
[موسيقى]
هذه دبابه خدمت كثيرا الجيش الامريكيه
ساعدته في حرب الخليج الاولى وكذلك اثناء
اجتياح العراق عام 2003 هذه الدبابه تخدم
بالفعل لدى القوات البريه الملكيه
السعوديه وتخدم حاليا لدى القوات البريه
لدوله الكويت كما يتم تصنيعه منها من طراز
اخر في مصر
[موسيقى]